Hi, I'm Nic Steenhout, and
this is the work between. Before
I get into what the show is, I
want to say whose land it's made
on. This podcast is recorded on
the traditional, ancestral, and
unceded territory of the Stolo
Coast Salish people, the people
of the river, whose presence in
the Fraser Valley stretches back
1000s of years. I name this
territory because it belongs
with what this show is about the
ways we decide whose lives are
valued, whose work is taken
seriously, and whose experiences
are treated as problems to be
managed. Those decisions shape
everything. This show sits
inside that. This is, was, and
always will be First Nations
land. That's not a formality.
It's consistent with everything
I and this show stand for.
This episode of the Work Between
is going to be a little
different. Usually, this podcast
is a conversation, an interview.
I sit down with someone and we
talk about creativity, identity,
disability, and the places where
those things intersect. Today,
it's just me.
Every creative practice develops
its own tradition, ways of
working that get passed along
because they've helped a lot of
people learn and become better
at what they do. But traditions
can also carry assumptions about
how we learn, about the
environment we work in, about
what our bodies and brains can
do or can't do. I've been
thinking about what happens when
those assumptions meet
disability, and about the
difference between changing what
we're trying to learn and
changing how we get there. Urban
sketching happens to be where
I've been encountering those
questions lately, so that's
where I'm going to start.
I've been thinking about urban
sketching. I mean, I think about
that a lot, so I should specify.
Lately, I've been thinking about
how we teach people to do urban
sketching, because if you spend
any time watching urban
sketching videos or taking
classes, you start hearing the
same advice: sketch from life,
draw directly in ink. Don't use
photo. Don't start with pencil.
There's good reasoning behind
most of that. Sketching on
location teaches you to observe
what's actually in front of you.
Drawing directly in ink can help
you commit to the lines you've
made. Working quickly can help
loosen some of that
perfectionism that can make
drawing more difficult. So I
understand the advice. A lot of
it is great advice. Where I have
a problem is when good advice
becomes a prescription for how
everybody is supposed to learn.
I'm disabled, and I'm very
conscious of how much some of
this advice assumes about the
person holding the sketchbook.
Urban sketching can make demands
on your body before you've even
started drawing. I often have to
use wheelchair if I see a
building I want to draw. I can't
necessarily wander around until
I find exactly the composition I
want, and then settle wherever
happens to give me the best
view. Maybe there's a curb,
maybe the ground is rough, or
there's a slope. Maybe the place
with the really good view is
somewhere I can't put my chair
without blocking the sidewalk.
Sometimes I have to use a cane
instead of wheelchair, and when
I use a cane, I have a
completely different experience.
I may be able to get to the
spot, but standing there for an
hour might hurt, or maybe I can
do it, but it uses so much
energy that I don't have
anything left afterward. And
then, of course, there's the
weather. Heat and cold aren't
always just a question of being
uncomfortable. For some disabled
people, temperature can
aggravate symptoms or affect the
health. Staying another half
hour because the drawing isn't
quite finished may not be a
reasonable choice. Once you've
found somewhere to draw, there's
everything has to deal with.
Pain and fatigue take attention,
so does filtering sound and
movement and everything else
happening around you. Some of us
arrive at the drawing with more
of our energy and attention
already spoken for.
Think about what your brain is
actually doing when you're
sitting on a busy street trying
to draw. You're looking at a
roof line, and you're trying to
understand where it's going.
Somebody walks in front of you.
There's a conversation happening
behind you. A truck goes past.
There's movement at the edge of
your vision. Someone stops, and
asks what you're drawing. Okay,
where was that roof line again?
a
I'm
effort, and that leaves less
attention available for figuring
out the drawing. For me,
something different happens. If
I already know how to do it.
And this is where photographs
become really useful for me. I'm
still learning perspective, and
an experienced sketcher may look
at a building and understand
that those lines are doing
almost without thinking about
it, I don't always see it yet.
Give me a photograph, though,
and I can stare at one roof line
for as long as I need it to. I
can follow it. I can look away.
I can come back to it. I can
compare it with another line. I
can get it wrong and try again.
A bus isn't going to pull up and
block the bit I'm studying. The
light isn't changing while I'm
trying to understand why
something looks the way it does.
At home, I can be a learner. I
can spend 20 minutes getting one
roof line wrong. Maybe I start
again and get it wrong a second
time. Maybe I make a complete
mess of the page. I can put the
sketchbook down. I can go grab a
drink. I can come back later, or
work in making those decisions
directly in ink.
come back tomorrow. Nobody is
watching me learn. Maybe it
shouldn't matter, but that's
important to me. On location, I
don't always give myself the
same permission. I become
conscious of doing this in
public. Someone can look over my
I'm sitting somewhere in public
with a sketchbook, I'm very
shoulder, someone can ask what
I'm drawing, and I start feeling
as though I should be producing
something worth looking at. When
what I'm actually trying to do
is figure out why those two
lines don't look the way I
expected them to? For somebody
else, that feeling may not
bother them at all. Maybe it's
the traffic they can't filter.
Maybe it's the conversation
behind them. Maybe it's
everything moving at once.
There's plenty of ways for a
busy street to ask too much of a
brain. Eventually, I want to sit
in front of the actual building
and recognize those
relationships there. That's one
of the things I want from urban sketching.
A photograph might be
scaffolding for me. Pencils
might be scaffolding. I can use
them while I'm learning
something, and maybe,
eventually, I don't need them
anymore. Some of the other
things I've been talking about,
those are different. I may get
to a point where I no longer
need a photograph to understand
a roofline, but I'm not going to
practice my way out of being a
wheelchair user. I'm still going
to need somewhere I can actually
put my chair. Someone who can't
comfortably stand for an hour
isn't going to become a better
artist and suddenly stop needing
to sit down. A neurodivergent
sketcher may always concentrate
better with earbuds, and someone
whose disability is affected by
heat isn't going to become more
skilled, or skilled enough that
a hot afternoon stops affecting
them. That's the difference
between scaffolding and
accommodation. One may help me
while I'm learning; the other
may simply be part of how I
sketch because I have no choice.
Think about stairs. What do I
actually need to do? I need to
get from one floor to another.
For a lot of people, stairs,
those work perfectly well. For
me, they don't. I don't need the
second floor lowered because I
use a wheelchair. I need another
way of getting there. If I'm
learning perspective, then yes,
I need to understand
perspective. Whether I can
filter the conversation at the
next table while I'm learning,
that's a different question.
Whether I feel like I'm
performing because somebody can
see my sketchbook doesn't tell
you whether I understand
perspective either. And being
able to stand on a street corner
for an hour doesn't make someone
better at seeing what's in front
of them. Somehow though, these
things can get bundled together
because they're part of the
traditional image we have of
urban sketching.
Which brings me back to the
Urban Sketcher manifesto. I like
that manifesto. Drawing on
location is at the heart of
urban sketching, and that's one
of the things that attract me to
it. Being there changes the
drawing. People move, vehicles
get in the way, the weather
changes. You notice something
you might never have thought to
photograph. You have to make
choices about what goes into
your drawing, you have to make
those changes because you can't
possibly put everything that's
happening on the one page. I do
want to get better at all of
that, but the manifesto doesn't
tell me how I'm allowed to
practice perspective before I
get there, and it doesn't tell
me what my body has to be
capable of once I arrive.
Somewhere along the way, draw on
location has picked up some
extra expectations. Don't
practice from photographs. Don't
use pencils. Find your view, sit
down, pull out your pen, and
draw while the city moves around
you. That's obviously a
perfectly good way to urban
sketch. It's just not available
to everybody. I wish we
understood that better. A
beginner sitting at their
kitchen table, trying to
understand the perspective of a
roof from a photograph, may be
preparing for the day when they
draw that building from life. At
home, they have somewhere they
can be a learner first. Once
we're outside, we're going to do
this differently too. I might
choose a less dramatic view
because that's where there's
room for my chair. Someone else
might put in earbuds. 20 minutes
may be enough for somebody else,
and when I take my sketchbook
outside, the things that make a
place accessible to me don't
suddenly stop mattering because
I've learned to draw better. I
still need somewhere I can
physically be. Someone else
still may need to control the
noise around them, or the
movement, or leave before
everybody else does. Sometimes I
need the street to hold still
for a while, so I can understand
what I'm looking at. When I'm
ready for it to start moving
again, I still need a place on
that street from which I can
draw.
If you enjoyed this episode, if
you were inspired in any way, or
if you learned something, please
leave a rating or review on
Apple Podcasts, on Spotify, or
whatever podcast aggregator you
use. Ratings and reviews really
do help. Thank you. And that's
it. I'm Nic Steenhout. This is
the work between. If this sounds
like the kind of conversation
you like. Subscribe, and I'll
see you in the next episode.